I know people I was trained to be a
teacher as a teacher you want the
students better than you are
it's after four or five years of begging
people to build tunnels and still no
tunnels I was like okay I want to go the
tunnel 95% of everything we do is right
every day in business but look for the
5% you do wrong and that's what makes
you better than everybody else wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best belief life and learn how
billionaires think so you can have more
success for yourself as well
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one make others happy with Jack
Ma I know nothing about technology I
know nothing but marketing I know
nothing about illegal all the staff and
do you know I don't know about people I
know people I was trained to be a
teacher as a teacher you want your
students better than you are you want
you've got your best product is just
students you wanted this student to be a
lawyer that's to become a banker that's
to be the entrepreneur that is a is a is
a layer you don't want don't want this
bankrupt that in the jail that is in
trouble
so you always want people better and
then you have to listen to them you want
to see their thing and then make the
older things to making sure that it can
empower them you can make them cheap
team work you can then collaborate so
this is how we do and I find the more
you care by a team the team will care
about you and the team will care about
their customers so I talk to all of my
people early days don't make me happy
don't love me make your customer happy
make your customer love you and I will
love you any minute that is very simple
so everything we do as its founder make
your customer happy
get your team make a team happy and you
will be happy
rule number two take care of your
customers with tillman Fertitta you know
the ninety nine ninety five five ruled
there are no spare you know ninety five
percent of everything we do is right
every day in business but look for the
five percent you do wrong and that's
what makes you better than everybody
else there are no spare customers okay
it's a competitive world and every one
of our businesses take no out of your
damned
cab you Larry you you're on a business
trip and it's 11:02 you hang up the
phone and and on a call and you call
down to order some breakfast and they so
I'm sorry sir we don't serve breakfast
anymore that's okay no problem I don't
need a waffle or or an eggs benedict
just throw a couple eggs and a skillet
and send them up scrambled however is
easy for you to do I'm sorry sir we
don't serve breakfast why are you
telling me no I didn't ask you for
anything special you're going to throw a
burger in the pan just throw me a couple
of eggs and take care of me
B you're in the hospitality business
okay and you're telling me no and
everybody's in the hospitality business
no matter what they do you take care of
your customer okay you take care of your
customers it's no different than we walk
in and your people meet us polite you
put a welcome up on the screen you come
in here everybody couldn't be can I get
you some water
tell me can can I do this for you you're
in the service business so why do you
want to be an ass and say no to somebody
when it's just as easy to say yes or you
just given up the company's being run by
somebody who's not rule number three be
rational with Warren Buffett I always
look at IQ and talent as sort of
representing the horsepower of the
border but then in terms of the output
the efficiency with which the motor
works that depends on rationality
because a lot of people start out with
four hundred horsepower motors and get a
hundred horsepower about but and it's
way better to have a 200 horsepower
motor and get it all in doubt put in and
so why do why do the smart people do
things that interfere with really
getting the output they're entitled to
and it's it gets into the habits into
character into temperament and it really
gets into behaving in a rational manner
it's and not letting not getting in your
own way as I say everybody here has the
ability absolutely to do anything I do
and much beyond and and some of you will
and some of you won't but it it will the
ones that won't well because because you
get in your own way it won't because the
world doesn't allow you to it will be
because you don't allow yourself to also
you want to have more confidence and
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free
the links are joined on the description
below there are times when something is
important enough you believe it enough
that you do it in spite of fear it's so
difficult to be a small business owner
in China it took me five months to once
500 dollars when I was selling copiers
door-to-door I had a very clear vision
of what my life was gonna be like rule
number four be a doer with Elon Musk
I remember when you first told me that
you were thinking about tunnels and I
must tell you about that the years ago
okay it's like a long time ago like I
thought you're joking yeah it was always
joking but it's not because of some
epiphany that I had one day driving on
the 405 that's how it gets called
translates and I was talking four
tunnels for years and years for probably
five years or four years at least
whenever I'd give a talk and people
would ask me about what opportunities
you do see in the world I'd say tunnels
can someone please build tunnels so
after four or five years of begging
people to build tunnels and still no
tunnels I was like okay I wonder will
the tunnel
like maybe a missing something here so
yes I was like basically talking feels
ears offal tunnels for several years and
then said well let's find out what it
takes the bullet tunnel and never so
started digging a tunnel I wanted to
start the tunnel from where I could see
it from my office at SpaceX it so stuff
I said well let's just cobble for part
of the parking lot across the road so I
can see if it's if anything's happening
or not and then we named our first
boring machine Godot because I kept
waiting for it
and no it came finally it did and and
regret it going and never making good
progress rule number five make
believability waited decisions with Ray
Dalio I should explain believability
weighted decision-making to you if you
sure you're interested ok so ordinarily
you're there with two ways of making
decisions pretty much there's the boss
as control and so on and Craddock Oya
Craddock I'll call that autocratic takes
in everything and then he makes a
decision or there's democratic pretty
much one man one vote but really the
best decision making is believability
weighted decision-making and if you
think about it first conceptually you
would say if you're gonna make a
decision of what you have medical
condition and you're going how are you
going to get that you're gonna think who
are the best doctors consult the experts
right consult the experts but this one
knows more and that one knows what less
and how do you do it and then you have
this triangulation and then you make
that that's kind of the idea
believability decision-making we have
ways of assigning believability that we
all agree are fair that we each assess
each other and we get certain amount of
believability points so now imagine that
you had believability
you're a believability on a subject
matter maybe it's investing maybe it's
accounting whatever the subject is that
you have a certain amount of
believability weighted points and you're
together
well those believable
liddie waiting points when you say okay
what should I make is a decision now I'm
responsible to something but I ask
everybody else I and I take a
believability weighted vote I can have a
believability weighted vote when I have
that believability way to vote vote I
really do believe that it's going to be
a better decision than I would
individually make that's believability
weighted decision-making rule number six
use humor to your advantage with Sara
Blakely I know that as part of the Spanx
training boot camp one of the mandatory
learning modules is comedy that every
employee has to go through so why is
that important I want it I didn't
understand why why everybody was so
serious so I thought you know what I
don't subscribe to the fact that you
have to act serious to be taken
seriously and I like to laugh at myself
I you know I looked when I worked in
corporate America for a long time and
everybody was super uptight and super
serious and there was no humor and there
was no levity and then everybody at like
5:00 o'clock became ragingly hilarious
like what what's going on like you know
and so the alcohol probably helped you
know but but anyway I I wanted to to use
humor and I love to do that in the
workplace and yes we have a boot camp at
spanks a training boot camp when you
come on board and one of the modules is
doing stand-up comedy and I've used the
comedic stuff that I did in my marketing
I mean I wrote don't worry we've got
your butt covered right on my package
when I first started in 2000 which was
not very common to do especially taking
it to the neiman-marcus to sell it I
named my company Spanx which was you
know made people laugh and believe it or
not it was very shocking at the time
that I named the company Spanx that
actually had people hang up on me often
I would call them and say hi I'm Sara
from Spanx and then they'd hang up and
I'd call back and I go I'm serious I'm a
real company and my company is called
spinning and they go oh oh I thought you
were prank calling me so and then you
know naming my products I broke into the
world's most boring category and can we
talk about shapewear who wants to talk
about shapewear and undergarments but it
was I named it power panties you know I
started naming all my products and it
made people laugh and it gave so much
and all of a sudden you had Gwyneth
Paltrow and Julia Roberts flashing their
Spanx on red carpets and saying I'm
wearing Spanx like all these celebrities
and I think it's because I chose to do
humor and people wanted to participate
in that there was energy around that so
so I use it in every aspect of of the
marketing I use humor to turn around a
situation when I'm bombing it it might
give me a second chance when I cold
called to sell fax machines door-to-door
for seven years I learned very quickly
that if I could make somebody laugh or
smile I'd get another 30 seconds before
they'd slam the door in my face there's
just it's helps you move through pain
it's it's it's a wonderful tool and rule
number seven the last one before a very
special bonus clip is be great at
selling with Mark Cuban if you come up
with an idea where you say I can make
dollar bills for 50 Cent's would you go
out and raise money or would you just go
out and sell it you just go out and do
it you know and that's what you have to
do and look we all go through that fear
factor of do I quit my job do I can I do
this can I can I do this and what
happens next the one thing I know with a
hundred percent certainty and what I
would tell myself is if I can sell and
become a better and better salesperson
and be great at selling I'm always going
to be successful whether I'm working for
myself or if the company that I started
just didn't work I'll give you an
example out of Indiana before I went
down to Dallas I needed to start
something and I decided that everybody
drank milk and I found this product
powdered milk that was cheaper and
everybody needed to save money and I was
going to go out there and sell it
because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good and so what I've but
I went out there to try to sell it
failed miserably but I learned how to
make the sales effort even when things
weren't going right I learned that the
rejection was every no got me closer to
a yes that not every product was perfect
but I could take those same
skills even in failure and translate
them so that what I learned selling
garbage bags door-to-door what I learned
from selling powdered milk that was
awful what I learned from selling local
area networks at micro solutions all
those things accumulated and I got
better at selling so I always knew you
know people always say to me if you lost
everything what would you do I can sell
I can sell when it's not about selling
ice to Eskimos it's not about you know
convincing people to do this selling is
always about helping selling is always
about understanding the person you're
talking to and what their needs are and
if someone can help me make my life
easier yeah people you know now with
employees people always say well like
what's the definition of a great
employee someone who can reduce the
stress of those around them and it's the
same thing what's the definition of a
great salesperson someone who can reduce
the stress of their salespeople and if
in looking at your company and looking
at your life and looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize that whether it works or
doesn't work you're putting yourself in
a position where you're helping somebody
not convincing somebody but and you're
reducing their stress you're gonna
you're gonna be ok it's gonna work out
and you know that's the confidence I've
built in myself that wasn't necessarily
always there but I learned that if I try
to help if I reduce people's stress good
things can happen now I have a special
bonus cut from Michael Bloomberg on how
to work hard that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to take an
action here we go question number one
who can you make happy today number two
how can you be more of a doer and number
three how can you better take care of
your customers this week and if you made
it this far in a video and you are
committed to making the change I want to
celebrate you give me a hashtag
we've down the comments as well I'm not
smarter than anybody else but I can
outwork you and my key to success for
you for anybody else's make sure you're
the first one in there every day and the
last one to leave don't ever take a
lunch break or go to the bathroom you
keep work and you never know when that
opportunity is going to come along and
it's Salomon Brothers the managing
partner of the company bill Solomon was
the second person in I was the only
other one in the big trading room so if
he had needed to borrow a match in those
days people smoked cigars and if he
wanted to ask something about a
newspaper or a stock he came over and so
we became buddies I would never have
gotten to talk to the managing partner
of a big company on a first-name basis
if it wasn't for the fact that the tools
are there Billy I'm getting coffee would
you like some and I can bring you in a
bit and at the end of the day the
number-two guy John good friend he was
the last one to leave except for me and
we'd share a cab going uptown or take
the subway train going uptown together
and you know every opportunity I ever
had it was I think good laughs a lot of
them was because I was there at the time
and that's the one thing you can control
you can continue can control your luck
but the harder you work the luckier get
you can't control that you're the
smartest guy they'll always be somebody
smarter but if you're there then you
absorb things you put things together in
the ways that if you didn't have all
that experience it's like skiing I've
said reading a book on skiing doesn't
teach you how to ski yeah you got to go
and you got a ski and get lots of miles
under your skis and incidentally if you
don't fall you're not skiing hard enough
and you're not learning anything so if
your career has ups and downs I got
fired didn't turn out so bad but you
know you can start a little business and
maybe it doesn't work and after a while
you got to be smart to say hey I tried
it don't let you go getting away I can't
keep doing this I've got to earn a
living but you know a year from now I'm
gonna come up with a better idea and
then I'll go back and do it again
if you want to know how you should start
your day tomorrow check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
you should never feel comfortable you
should be happy and dissatisfied too
many of you are sitting around waiting
to feel ready